bro I can hear your the vehicle in the
background all
right man Tik Tok man it's just so
ghetto how you doing good how about you
I'm pretty good pretty good thank you
for asking are you a
Muslim yeah all right welcome to the
stage man how how would you like to
engage with the uh with the topic
here yeah um it says prove Jesus was
Muslim right that's
right so yeah uh do you know what Muslim
means I have a definition of Muslim but
I'm willing to go with whatever you
say what is your
definition well the Quran says in
chapter 4 verse 65 it says uh but no
they will not truly believe until they
make you Muhammad judge in all their
disputes and find within themselves no
resistance against your decisions and
submit with full submission so you can't
truly be a Muslim until you submit to
Muhammad with full
submission so um that a refers
to um a Believer a True Believer which
is Ean which is like the second level
the first one is um once to so there's
Islam right and once you believe in
Islam become Muslim then there's IM
belief and when you become a True
Believer become a m that that that verse
is talking about a mman and not a Muslim
there's a step before being a mman which
is being a Muslim and do you know a
Muslim uh I don't think you answer my
question but what does a Muslim mean I
thought I did answer but you're saying
that a Believer is not necessarily a
Muslim there's a two different things no
no no I'm saying that a person could be
a Muslim but
but not a Believer to be no no no to be
a True Believer is a state you reach
after you reach some
qualifications can all right all right
so here's my question can you be a
Muslim without being a
Believer can you be a Muslim without
being a Believer
yeah you could be a
Muslim yes yes so you could be a
disbeliever and still be a
Muslim no no so that's that's that's
what I'm saying they go hand in hand you
can't be a Bel you can't be a Muslim and
not a Believer no I'm talking about I'm
talking I'm talking about that ay
reverse um the Ayah talks about True
Believer which is something yeah well if
you're not a True Believer then you're a
false believer right no no no no it's
that's not how it works so this is like
something you learn like the basics of
Islam you know like but I'm all right
basically let me tell you what Muslim
means real quick so Muslim yeah I'll go
with I'll go with your definition if
like like I said I I said I had a
definition but I'm willing to go with
whatever you say and then we can move
from there yeah I was just I was just
telling you that you're taking that Ayah
out of context but yeah we can go
through um
basically uh okay no problem so
basically a Muslim is a person who
believes in the Oneness of Allah right
and he submits his will to the one
Creator right yeah and that and you're
asking how Jesus was a Muslim Jesus
lived before Islam he lived um yes
before like before uh Prophet Muhammad
was on earth right right so he even in
your Bible it says that Jesus admits his
will to the father right
mhm and we Muslims and you Christians we
uh we agree that that in somewhat the
father is what we call Allah so you
believe that Allah is the father of
Jesus no no no no no no no I'm saying
that the word use as the
father we use as Allah you know the one
Creator no no the word the word Allah
and the word father are two different
things so cuz so you're saying you're
saying that when you say that when Jesus
submits to his father you're saying his
father is Allah that he's submitting to
is that right
right can you repeat that when you say
that Jesus submitted to his father the
father you're saying that that the
father is Allah
right in your definition the father Yes
we say Allah that's not that's not my
that's not my definition of father
that's not the any definition of father
what type of Christian are you there's
only one
kind I know what type of Christian are
you though what do you mean one type
there's only one kind oh if you okay to
be specific I'm I'm an original Quran
only Christian to be specific
are you Catholic I'm I'm original Quran
only Christian it's kind of a newer but
fastest growing you know religion all
right all right anyways um so basically
you know you do realize that Christians
call the Father Allah right Allah is
just a word in Arabic used for the one
Creator so Allah is a word and father is
another word right yeah IL is God uhhuh
and Allah is like the god you know like
I know you don't brother you don't have
to break down that word to me so so
Allah is one word and father or AB in
Arabic is another word
right okay okay is
Allah AB is he the
father he is not no no uh no in in the
Quran no no exactly he's not exactly you
don't refer him to we don't refer him to
father right so so if so when the
Christians are referring
to God their father they're not talking
about Allah of the Quran
right I
mean uh I would differ but if that's the
way you see it it can't be like for
example let's say let's just uh switch
it up a little bit let's say someone had
a statue that they called
Allah okay is that is that the same
Allah that's in the Quran of
Islam no because because the Allah of
Islam is not a statute right correct
he's the one Creator yeah right so when
the Christians are referring to Allah
their father the Arabic Christians
they're not talking about the Allah of
Islam that's a different Allah right how
is it different because Allah is not a
father I mean just like Allah is not a
statute so you're saying that statute's
Allah that's that's a different Allah so
it's not the same he's not a statute
same here Allah's not a father so
whoever they're calling a father is
different from the Allah of
Islam but linguistically like the father
as in like he you
know he created you you know your
sustenance and everything comes from him
you know
like ask what do mean is is is Allah a
father in any sense is there any sense
any sense that Allah is a
father to my knowledge there's uh I
think so there's three ways of father
right there's adopt there's biological
and there is what there's you have
adoption you have uh being the source of
a thing you have um spiritual father
right you you know caretaker all these
kind of things in which someone can be
deemed as a father in some senses in any
sense is Allah a father
is Allah a father in any sense yeah
islamically I mean the root word you
know English is my f is in my first
language so I don't want to say anything
that will like take me out of the fold
of Islam so I would say like um I like
you man you're honest about father if
you're talking about father as in like
he like you came from Allah like he he
is your creator he takes care of you and
everything like I can understand from
that sense but like you don't use the
word Allah or or no you don't use the
word father because it's like a way of
you're like lowering Allah you know
fathers they have they have weaknesses
right so to so to refer to Allah as
father would be a disrespect to him and
his
status yes correct so he's not a father
in any way
right yes I'll see that yeah okay I
would see that all right so right cool
so we can work with this so because
Allah is not a father in any way when
Christians are calling God their father
they're not talking about Allah then
even though they might be using the word
Allah in Arabic you know because of the
occupation and all whatever happens the
history they're referring to their God
as Allah right just as the generic term
for God but they call him father they
call him AB so that's not the same Allah
that is in Islam can we
agree wh why would you say that I mean I
think Arab Christians would disagree
with you right if I brought up Arab
Christians right now all of them would
would happily with a quickness before I
can blink say that the god that they're
talking about is nowhere near the same
God in
Islam so so you're so you're saying
you're saying just because you're making
a correlation that just because they use
the same word Allah that that has to be
the same entity that you're talking
about we just we just we just f f I need
you to focus man Focus so that we don't
backtrack we just demonstrated that just
because you're using the same word for
something doesn't mean you're talking
about the same thing for example what's
your name
bro uh Abdi Abdi okay your name's ABD
how old are you if you don't mind me
asking I'm 20 20 okay so ABD is 20 all
right now let's say I I say wow man I I
I uh I met you before you know we we
we've been friends um the obdi that I
know he's he's 25 years old and he's a a
a 68 black man who plays in the NBA is
that the same am I talking about the
same person is that you no so even
though the name is the same or the word
is the same I'm talking about two
completely different entities right
uh yeah so so the the same way just
because Muslims use the word Allah and
some Arabic Christians may use the word
Allah doesn't mean they talking about
the same God because the Muslim Allah is
not a father in any way shape or form
and to even say that it's disgusting it
causes the Earth to to shake and the
mountains to crumble in the universe to
rupture that's chapter 19 Ser Marian by
the way to even say that right to say he
has a son exactly you're no it's the
same thing to to say that he's a father
is to say that he has a son or a
daughter no to say no to take a son with
the father
yeah this this is amazing so you have
here where Allah is not a father in any
way shape or form Christians Arabic
Christians who use the word Allah say
that God is their father so that's not
the same Allah as the one in Islam right
I'm pretty sure AR Christian would
disagree with you I would disagree with
you uh you can bring AR Christian right
now I'm asking you is it the same Allah
no oh yeah oh it is the same so then
Allah is a father in Islam then we don't
use the term of the father but I don't
care what you I don't care what you use
is he a father no he's not a father then
it's not the same Allah as the Quran as
as the Christians because their Allah is
a father
right I mean okay so
please I don't know please don't play
dumb don't play dumb I'm not I'm not
playing dumb I'm just saying like you
like you're taking stuff like you're
trying to sound like you know what
you're saying but the only thing I'm
doing bro is using freaking logic and
common sense that's all so maybe it
might sound it might it might it might
sound to the person who maybe lacks
common sense and lacks you know like
just common thinking and critical
thinking it might sound like I'm saying
something just scientifically I mean
amazing maybe something super profound
maybe to that person but dude I'm
telling you nothing I'm saying is
profound or super smart I'm just using
common freaking sense
man I would say you're misrepresenting
Arab Christians I mean you can bring one
up if you want I don't care I don't I
don't I don't care what you what you
think I'm doing just follow the logic
does the logic follow is Allah a father
you said no so when Christians say that
their Allah is a father is that the same
Allah it's the same Allah but whether
they call him the father or whatever
name they give him at the end of day
they're referring to the same one
Creator got it okay so the same thing
with the with the polytheist who say
that their statute is Allah if they say
their statute is Allah the Creator
that's the same Allah in in Islam right
they why not but no no no but they think
it's the creator of all things all right
let me ask a question what is the
difference between the AR stop they
think that their statute is the creator
of all things and they call it Allah
what's the difference how is it not your
Allah all right let me answer we're not
referring to the same thing because we
say that Allah is a uncreated being but
they they say that their Allah is a
created Idol no they say their Allah is
uncreated they're just referring to the
statute as Allah the the uncreated
Creator is it the same
I'm not gonna lie my head I bet it
does maybe next time man take care
thanks for
coming when you're a
Muslim it I I can imagine
it when you are when your logic is being
pressed out of the box of Islam like
like this this is this is the ceiling
right this is the ceiling of the box
right
right and the Muslim this is the logic
that is like when you when you're being
pressed to get past the ceiling of the
box of a Muslim and your logic is
pressing forward it may it's gonna hurt
man it's gonna be uncomfortable for a
second it is it's not going to be
comfortable it's it's gonna be a strain
watch this now it's going to be a strain
it's going to be difficult it's going to
be tough to to break past that the the
ceiling but when you're doing it it may
hurt a little bit but press forward man
because once you open up you're free and
you're just flowing and you're out of
Islam you know longer have to have
headaches when you think